[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 119 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mock mantle and I'm here with my
colleague as always
Melanie work Melanie how are you doing
today I'm doing good mark how are you
and we have a special cause with us
tonight you have a very special co-host
for this today Cheryl how are you doing
today I'm doing great thanks for having
me excellent thank you so much for
joining us we are talking to Nvidia
today which is actually a really
interesting discussion on our interview
definitely we're going to be getting
into more the details around GPUs and AI
in our interview later on with Brian but
before we do that as always we go into
the cool things of the week and we have
a question of the week and this week's
question we're going to and this is part
of the reason why Cheryl's joining us
today we want to talk about GDC the Game
Developers Conference that is going on
as we speak and that you and Cheryl will
be attending so we want to talk about
what you guys find is exciting and as
veterans of GDC what do ya'll recommend
to those who might be new or exploring
it for the first time but first as
always we like to get into our cool
things of the week and one of the cool
things of the week is that we have the V
100's which is the NVIDIA GPU and that
is coming to Google cloud that will be
available in all the clouds all the
Google cloud all the Google clouds all
the Google cloud there's a lot of Google
clouds yeah I wanna have a quick plug
for a blog post written by one of our
fellow Dubrow members at Chris Broadfoot
here in San Francisco also fellow
Australian and guest on the podcast
previously nice there we go
he wrote a blog post talking about
automatic serverless deployments with
Google cloud repositories in container
builder he has a great blog post talking
through how you can build ci and CD
pipelines using cloud functions source
repositories container builder it's
actually really easy to do
I've done it for the seei pipeline for
gun is it's actually kind of cool how
much you can get done with just a few
bits of JavaScript and some cloud
builder scripts nice and Cheryl did you
have something you wanted to share oh
yeah two of the projects on the magenta
team have had a launch this past week
it's been really exciting a lot of but
it's interesting because one is
on the research side of machine learning
and creativity and then the second one
is on the the product ization of
creative machine like machine learning
for creativity so both of these for the
research side we have music VA e and on
the product side we have incent super
which is an open-source piece of
hardware that runs machine learning
models to generate sounds for music
that's pretty cool awesome
we'll have to dive into more detail in a
later I think we might have to do a
Magento episode well so the last thing
we want to mention for this week in
terms of cool things of the week is that
there's this great article out there on
the building blocks of interpretability
and we'll share a link in the show notes
as always what this article goes over is
the different techniques and approaches
that have been used and explored for
interpretability for machine learning
especially neural Nets like feature
visualization attribution and
dimensionality reduction but it's
looking at it and trying to take those
approaches as building blocks and
combine them and that's what's unique in
this article in particular and and it's
trying to do it in a way that's human
scale as it says something that's an
understandable by humans so we'll share
that's interesting and yeah I think that
covers us for cool things of the week
awesome well why don't we go have a chat
with that buddy over in the video sounds
good let's do that so on this week's
podcast we are excited to have join us
Brian Catanzaro who is the VP of Applied
deep learning research at Nvidia hey
good afternoon and so Brian can you tell
us a little about yourself in the work
that you're doing now and the work
you've done in the past sure so I lead a
team of researchers here at Nvidia
that's focused on using deep learning to
make in videos products butter and
invidious processes better and so we're
looking at a bunch of different ways of
using AI and lots of different domains
ranging from video games to chip design
and all sorts of stuff in between so
it's an exciting time to be working in
AI applications there's a lot of
diamonds on the beach waiting for people
to pick them up and change the way that
we do things and so it's a pretty
exciting project definitely and you know
in terms of Nvidia I know in videos led
the way when it comes to GPUs and GPUs
have played such a significant role in
the deep learning space as well as the
gaming space
we were talking about this actually
right before we started the podcast but
how impressive it is that Nvidia
strategy around GPUs in particular has
shifted over the last few years alone
you know and can you speak to that a
little bit you know I think NVIDIA has
always had a strong belief that GPUs as
a throughput oriented processor we're
going to change the world beyond gaming
and more than ten years ago and video
started investing in CUDA which is our
language and and sort of ecosystem for
programming throughput oriented
computers and at the beginning we were a
little bit less certain about what
applications were going to need this
power and what was actually going to
change in the world because we had this
new way of thinking about algorithms and
computation but I think the belief has
been consistent and the focus has been
there for a long time deep learning
happened to be the most important of all
the applications that need
high-throughput computation and so once
Nvidia saw that it was basically instant
you know the whole company latched on to
it because they realized this is our
chance to make a difference and you know
I I happen to be involved in that a
little bit you know I was one of the
very first people working on deep
learning back at Nvidia research back in
2012 and you know we we were having fun
and and doing this research project and
like many research projects it wasn't
clear to me at the time like whether
this was going to be something fun or
whether this was going to be something
that really changed the world but the
amount of interest in our work was
really surprising like the the results
were good and people started paying a
lot of attention to it and I started
meeting with a lot of different people
at Nvidia and they kind of saw the whole
company kind of saw like wow this this
could be really big for us and so that
everybody latched on to do you remember
a specific time when you were doing that
research that stood out to you that made
you go oh wow this is this is much more
impactful than I expected or specific
moment that comes to mind yeah so one of
the things that attracted some attention
we published a paper at ICML in 2013 and
this was me collaborating with a group
of researchers at Stanford and
including Adam Coates and Andrew Inge
where we were able to take approach to
unsupervised learning that was pioneered
actually in the Google brain team by
koala and we were able to replicate that
using far far fewer computers so Kwok
had published this paper in 2012 and he
needed something like a thousand nodes
in order to train this model and we were
able to train the model with three nodes
using GPUs and more efficient software
that was kind of a little bit more HPC
focused and so we published this paper
at ICML and people like wow this is
really exciting because it democratizes
the work you know if if it makes deep
learning a thing that you can do on
three nodes instead of a thousand than
the number of people that can start
applying this technology to new problems
just goes up dramatically and that that
was that was something that caught a lot
of attention and just to confirm when
you're talking about what you were
working on this is ku DNA so this was
actually before KU DN a-- and existed so
yeah so I did this with Adam and Andrew
and that was really exciting and I
started talking to more deep learning
researchers and actually the person that
that inspired me to make CUDA ninh was
Rob Fergus who was a professor at New
York University one of John the Coons
collaborators and I think Rob is now at
Facebook and Rob was like look we are
doing all these convolutional models all
the time and we've written our own
convolutions but we think it's a lot of
work to make them fast and nvidia gpus
change all the time because you know
that's the primary way nvidia innovates
is by making the architecture better but
then that means that the software needs
to adapt to the new architecture and so
Rob was telling me like we're spending
too much time working on these kernels
we think Nvidia should make a library
for it and I thought yeah that's a great
idea so then I set about convincing the
rest of Nvidia that they should make
this product and it took a little bit of
work so while I was convincing them I
just started writing the code for a
research prototype and then as the
conversations progressed things got more
concrete and then finally people kind of
caught the vision and decided yes we
should productize this and that that
became kuden n so this sounds really
cool I know it was reset before on the
podcast melanie's the ml's expert and
i'm sort of the person who knew the
gaming I expel you understands math for
those people who aren't as familiar with
like this eco suit
and maybe you're more like doesn't in
video making cards first up we do yeah
like how does that translate to doing
like what is that pathway from like I
have a graphics card I thought it was
just for graphics why is it also
applicable or how is it also applicable
to doing what seems to be like intense
mathematical calculations when you draw
a picture in a 3d game you're
essentially running a lot of programs
that figure out what every pixel looks
like and over the years those programs
have gotten more complex as you might
expect and also a lot more flexible it
used to be that GPUs were very fixed
function machines where you kind of just
gave it a list of triangles in it it
rasterized them but nowadays to do the
complex lighting and texturing and
reflections and so forth all that is
done by writing programs but very
parallel programs and so it turns out
actually that the workload in modern
games often is majority of the time is
being spent running compute programs
rather than running traditional graphics
workloads and so there's been an
evolution and graphics towards more
flexibility more parallel computing and
less fixed function graphics and so GPUs
have had to evolve to support that at
the same time you know if you have a
really high throughput parallel
processor that can be used for arbitrary
computation turns out there's a lot of
things that you can do with it including
AI well and I'm curious how did you even
get involved with parallel processing
compute you know what what inspired you
to go down this path to begin with yeah
when I was an undergrad I did some
internships at Intel and I was working
on circuit design and I made some really
really fast circuits that were gonna run
at like 10 gigahertz and this is four
transistors that hadn't even been built
yet so we were kind of dreaming about
the future and trying to build it and we
kept figuring out that the power
consumption was going to be impossible
like there was just no way that we were
going to be able to make single threaded
computer that held on to the performance
scaling trends that everyone expected so
I saw I saw it Intel this realization
that the world of computing in the
future must become parallel and so when
I went to graduate school
I decided to focus on parallel computing
frameworks for programming parallel
computers and applications of parallel
computers and the one that really struck
me as most promising was machine
learning and so that's how I ended up
spending my my PhD on programming
frameworks for parallel processors and
machine learning applications because I
felt like that was the most important
thing you could do with a parallel
computer nice and then I know in terms
of your background you know you were
here you're working on ku DNN and then
you made a shift and you you joined by I
do working on machine learning with I do
and then you've come back that's right
what's let's to that trajectory well so
I mentioned before that my kind of
introduction to the world of deep
learning happened with Andrew Inge and
Adam Coates they founded this lab at
Baidu the Silicon Valley AI lab and
asked me to come join them and I felt
like it was a great opportunity for me
to get closer to applications you know I
really loved working on ku DNN I'm very
proud of it
and I felt like I want to be a little
bit closer to how we take AI and make it
into something that solves a problem but
that people really need to be solved and
so I felt like working with the Silicon
Valley AI lab at Baidu gave me a great
chance to get closer to applications and
then you know I'd been there for about
two and a half years and I felt like I
had accomplished my mission was looking
around to figure out what my next
project should be and Jennsen Wong
Nvidia CEO called me up and said hey
we'd really like you to come back to
Nvidia and found a lab focused on
research figuring out how to apply AI to
problems that we have in Nvidia and I
thought well that's great because I love
Nvidia I've always you know been sort of
an ally of Nvidia because I believe in
the technology and a chance to come back
and focus on the applications that I
really wanted to do it seemed like a
great opportunity what kind of
applications do you work on so my team
right now is mostly focused on three
areas one of them is graphics one of
them is text and the other is audio yes
so with graphics we're really excited
about the opportunities to change the
way that graphics is created and
rendered by using deep learning we have
a paper actually in this year's cvpr
that
is about a generative model for creating
graphics photorealistic high-resolution
graphics given very simplistic input
images and so the the idea would be that
we could create a new kind of graphics
engine where the traditional graphics is
actually doing very little work at all
and the majority of the graphics
rendering is being done by a generative
model and the advantage of doing that
would be that we believe it will be far
cheaper to create virtual worlds because
in order to create a new world we just
need to train a new model rather than
spend a lot of money with an army of
artists that can you know manually
create all the textures and lighting
that go into that environment so we're
pretty excited about that and we feel
like there's a lot of applications for
AI in graphics and so so that's one of
the things going on in my group we're
also working on some text problems we're
really inspired by this open AI paper
doing unsupervised learning for text
classification specifically sentiment
analysis where you train a model to
reconstruct a large text database
character by character and it turns out
that in so doing your model has to
understand the meaning of the text not
just the characters in the text and you
can use that with just a little bit of
labels to to solve some some really
applied problems like sentiment analysis
and so we're working on stuff like that
and then in the audio space right now
we're working on some things related to
speech and speech synthesis so so in
terms of doing this type of work you're
trying to also set it up to make it
accessible to users of the GPUs I assume
absolutely
yeah one of the great things about
working at Nvidia is that we get to open
source a lot of the work that we're
doing in fact all the projects that I'm
mentioning we have either open sourced
or we're in the process of open sourcing
and one of the reasons that we can do
that is because the more we inspire
other people to do AI then the better it
is for NVIDIA because so much of AI
happens on GPUs and so we can make the
world a better place by giving people
new technology that they can use to
solve problems and it also helps in
videos business and so it's a great
thing for us
you open-source our work right and then
I know you've done the work in the past
on kudiye and really driving software to
help people optimize working on GPUs but
then there's GPUs that have been
actually built specifically volta to
help with deep learning can you speak to
a little bit about volton how it works
and helps people improve their
processing of dof deep learning yeah so
volta is the first GPU that Nvidia made
kind of after it woke up to the
possibilities of deep learning and
NVIDIA believes I think more strongly
than than any other organization that
I've seen in the power of specialized
architecture you know that's kind of
really what has made Nvidia successful
from the beginning is the company builds
chips to solve important problems and
that are tailored to those particular
problems so when Nvidia decided deep
learning is the most important thing
that we're going to be using our GPUs
for the next step was to customize the
architecture for deep learning and volt
has the first fruits of that effort and
so the computational capabilities of
volta are really astounding you know it
one voltage ep you can run at over a
hundred and twenty teraflops when you're
training a model and that's you know
about ten times faster then the the
speed that you would get on our prior
generation GPU and so that's that's
really exciting capability how does the
architecture for something like voltar
differ from something like a graphics
GPU Volta is different in a lot of ways
from our previous GPUs it's just a lot
more focused on compute workloads so
especially the memory subsystem has been
beefed up to handle the kinds of data
patterns that that are required in in a
lot of compute workloads it also has a
lot faster integer arithmetic which is
really useful for addressing math and
you know more I would say complicated
workloads where you need to do a lot of
indexing math to figure out what data
you're going to load and operate on so
the whole architecture has been revamped
and then in addition to all those other
features we added tensor cores which are
essentially matrix multiply units that
can do small matrix four by four by four
matrix multiplications and the thing
that's really great about tensor cores
is that they dramatically reduce the
energy cost of reading and writing the
operands from the register file because
the majority of the work happens inside
of this bigger chunkier unit and you
don't have to be constantly reading and
writing all the intermediate results to
a register file and so that dramatically
reduces the energy that's required to do
a matrix multiplication which then makes
the processor dramatically more
efficient nice
so you mentioned about teraflops can you
help for those who might not understand
teraflops exa flops explain a little bit
you are I guess in layman's terms what
that means and what they can really
conceptualize in terms of speed yeah
well it's hard actually for humans to
understand these numbers because they're
really big numbers but so Tara is 10 to
the 12 so 120 teraflops you know that's
some 120 trillion math operations per
second which is a lot yeah that is a lot
and you know training a deep learning
model can often require exaflop so after
Tara comes peda so that's 10 to the 15
and after Pettitte comes Excel which is
10 to the 18 and so training a deep
learning model routinely takes tens of
EXA flops I like to point out that
people often estimate the number of
grains of sand on planet earth at about
10x a grains of sand so if you're doing
10x of flops it's kind of like a
multiplier or an ADD for every single
grain of sand and and you do that every
time you train a model so it's extremely
computationally intense and it turns it
around I mean the speed at which it can
turn around some of these models that
are becoming larger and larger and have
more data that they're trying to
processes it has its impact it's it's
very important at the end of it is yeah
yeah I mean when you're trying to solve
a problem with AI you have to iterate
because it's a search right like you
have to find the right model you have to
find the right hyper parameters you have
to find the right data and that requires
a lot of search and so as you create a
model and you train it you learn things
about it you learn when it is doing well
you learn when it's not doing well you
find bugs you fix
parameters this requires training a
model many many times and the quicker
you can do it the faster a developer can
iterate and that leads to better results
and so people find that having access to
this kind of compute capability it not
just makes the work go faster but it
actually changes the kind of problems
that they can attempt because that
there's problems that they can try that
they just never would have been able to
try without it
and when you talk about training there's
training and there's also inference and
so volta is a wonderful GPU to be using
from a training perspective you know is
that's also architected for inference or
do you have other options specifically
and I know the answer but I wanted to
give you the chance to yeah so let me
explain a little bit of the difference
between training and inference first so
training is a search like I said you're
trying to find a model so the model may
have hundreds of millions or billions of
parameters and you need to fine tune
every one of those to find the right
number and so it's a it's a search and
you're searching for it guided by your
data and so we we often talk about back
propagation what that means is you do
forward propagation where you use the
model to make a guess about what the
output should be say if we're doing
speech recognition and the input is a
WAV file and the output is text so we
run a bunch of WAV files through and we
get the guesses for what those WAV files
contain but then we know what the right
answer should be and we have what's
called labels we can use those labels to
figure out what the error was you know
what where was the model wrong and then
we use that to update the weights just
tweak them just a little bit and we do
that you know a million times or a
billion times right and so through this
process it's kind of evolutionary we we
search through the space to find a good
model so that's that's the training
process the serving process or inference
process that's just performing the
forward propagation or given an input
what is the output of that model so
we're just pushing the data forward
through the model just the prediction or
the classification and classification so
that computationally is simpler because
you know it's only doing the forward
pass it's not doing the backward pass
and it's not doing the learning but it
has different characteristics
algorithmically and so
makes sense to have software and
hardware that is tailored for both of
them in different ways and so it turns
out Volta is actually a great GPU for
inference I'm I'm actually very excited
about using Voltas for inference the
biggest problem I think right now with
with Voltas is that there's just not
enough Voltas in the world and we make
all the Voltas that we make get sucked
up to go into training because people
need that so much whereas inference
workloads they're often smaller and so
people can get by with with smaller
processors but I do believe in the
future that we're going to see big
inference workloads that require even a
Volta to deploy so so I am excited about
both training and inference for Volta
but NVIDIA also has other products
specifically designed for the inference
market for example the Tesla p4 it's a
small I think it's 50 to 75 watt GPU and
it has some low precision arithmetic
instructions because in inference you
don't need nearly as many bits in order
to get a good result as you do during
training and so so the the tesla p4 is a
really good ops ii per watt processor
for the the inference market you said
something interesting just before where
you were talking about with the newer
GPUs you were able to do things you
weren't possibly able to do before
mostly inspirationally what are the
things that you're able to do now that
you weren't actually able to yeah for
well I'll I'll speak a little bit to
graphics because we're really excited
about that and at Nvidia but recently
there's been some incredible generative
models for graphics that that we've seen
including the progressive Gann which
generates very high resolution very high
quality images you know they they
trained it on the celeb face data set
and the the faces that it generates are
pretty indistinguishable from real
pictures of people even though they're
completely invented by this model and I
think the you know the leap in fidelity
for Ganz when you are able to train them
on larger data sets for longer periods
of time is quite incredible and changes
the kinds of applications you can do
with ganz the paper that I mentioned
that we've been working on about
synthesizing photorealistic images from
semantic labels that that work also I
think is pretty surprising like I often
look at the output of that model and I
it takes me quite a long time to figure
out like is this a fake image or is this
a real image and that just would not
have been possible without the this
processing power when I first met you
you were doing a presentation on
parallelizing data for you know models
versus paralyzing a model and there were
different methodologies in terms of how
do you split out especially if you're
trying to do mass processing of deep
learning model in particular how do you
break that out if you wanted to try to
do distributed computing what are your
thoughts now in terms of distributed
computing for deep learning do you see
that is really a thing to do or do you
see just making these chips better we
need both so the great thing about
making the chip butter is that it plugs
into the software environment without
disruption or the disruption is much
less and so that allows people to
smoothly move from one generation to the
next and get performance improvements
without having to do big changes to
their code and it also you know there's
an accessibility argument as well you
know a lot of people doing AI research
are operating on a smaller scale and so
if we can make the small scale
processing better and better then that
really helps accessibility and sort of
democratizing this technology and then
for for people that have the resources
to use more processors to train a model
then being able to have the software
scale to using many GPUs to train one
model provides really compelling
benefits and so we need that as well and
we focus on both of those things at
Nvidia nice you've mentioned a number of
different groups in terms of their work
and what's going on out there and the
deep learning space and a machine
learning how much are you collaborating
with other outside groups how do you
collaborate with you know like opening
eye Facebook Google Nvidia collaborates
with pretty much everyone we I think we
work pretty hard on our relationships
with research labs and
em'ly clubs and industrial labs though
the way we collaborate we we like to
basically help people solve problems so
people often come to us and say you know
are we're having problems getting good
efficiency with this particular model
can you help us and we'll look into it
and realize oh kudi NN is choosing the
wrong implementation for this particular
convolution in this particular case so
we can change the heuristic and make
that more efficient or we can may maybe
add a new implementation for one of
those primitives that turns out can be a
lot better fitted to the architecture
and so we're constantly iterating with
researchers from all over the world
about what their needs are and how we
can make our products better what are
you most excited about in terms of where
things are going with AI and machine
learning you know I'm really excited
about applications that's what I'm doing
right for a living I feel like there are
just so many new ways of applying this
technology to pretty much every field
inside the world economy you know we we
talk a lot about self-driving cars and
I'm very excited about self-driving cars
I think self-driving cars are one of the
applications that are kind of on the
vanguard of really changing the world
you know I'm really excited about never
having to find a parking spot again and
like you know building houses where all
those parking lots are that that would
be really great here in the Bay Area
where there's not enough space yeah so I
think everybody's excited about
self-driving cars but I think that's
just the beginning you know I think
every industry from agriculture to
education to art you know there's just
going to be an explosion of applications
of AI and it's exciting to be part of
that and for those who are starting out
wanting to get into I mean even just
doing chip design or trying to get into
parallel processing and and do you
learning it do you have any
recommendations or any things that you
know you'd say I could spend some time
working on or some resources that come
to mind
yeah well let's see there's a couple
things on my mind right now one of them
so I saw Google put out a class recently
and sort of introduction to machine
learning I looked through that briefly
it looked pretty good so that that seems
like an interesting thing to look at
Nvidia also has
something called the deep Learning
Institute where we give tutorials to
help people get hands-on experience
training models and using deep learning
frameworks I think that that has been
pretty interesting for some people I'm
also a fan of some of these online
education programs I'm for example I
work with Udacity Udacity has some some
great nano degrees in AI that I think
people can get a lot of value from going
through and then I guess the two other
things that also come to mind are open
source so like there's just so much out
there if you search on the open source
on github you can find implementations
of all sorts of really amazing deep
learning models and you can download
them for free and just start playing
around with them you don't even need to
build a machine that has a GPU in it you
can use a cloud service like the Google
plug and NMS nice thank you thank you
you can get started really easy right
you don't you don't have to invest a
whole bunch to jump in and then I guess
the last thing that I wanted to mention
also you know I feel like I'm
advertising for Google here but but it
is actually a really good thing as
kaggle so Kaggle is this online
competition where people can try to
solve real problems using AI and you
know as a as somebody that's always
looking for talent to come help us apply
AI to new problems when I see a resume
with somebody that's been competitive in
in Catalan I feel like wow this is a
person who is excited about jumping in
to solve problems and it's very hands-on
and I think Kaggle is a great way to
learn practical skills about applying AI
awesome awesome one question before we
end up wrapping up as someone who's been
involved especially on like the
computational side of things for such a
long period and seen seeing the history
I'm curious to hear about what's been
the most surprising thing for you with
my surprising application you've seen
come out of this stuff or maybe even the
most interesting or weird or wacky well
one of one of the most surprising and
weird and wacky papers that I saw
recently was this one called the deep
image prior basically what they're doing
is instead of training a deep learning
model on like a million images they
train a deep learning model on one image
and
super crazy idea but the results are
actually kind of compelling that they're
able to do some tasks like image
completion like imagine that you have
like a part of the image that's damaged
and you want to repair it they're able
to fill in that image by training a deep
learning model just on that very single
image all by itself I thought that was
that was pretty crazy you know I I think
there's a ton of interesting
applications in agriculture you know I
remember this blog post from Google
actually about the cucumber sorting if
you guys remember that I think that one
of our colleagues put that one together
actually yeah I loved that blog post I
always reference it because it was very
surprising to me that like I don't know
too many cucumber farmers so my image of
them is maybe a little wrong but I just
wouldn't imagine a cucumber farmer
picking up tensorflow and training a
model to solve like a problem that they
had on their farm and I thought that was
really cool agreed that was definitely a
fun one well as Mark was mentioning I
know we're getting short on time but was
there anything else that you wanted to
touch on or cover before we before we
let you go yeah I guess one of the
things that I think is really important
in the advancement of AI is the software
environment maybe that's obvious to say
but we still have a lot of work to do to
make it better and the environments that
we have now represent a huge amount of
investment and I think sometimes we take
them for granted but I just wanted to
sort of highlight that as we progress
forward there's a lot of different ways
of increasing compute capacity for deep
learning and for AI and I think that
it's important for all of us to remember
that it has to sort of connect all the
way to the developers and the way that
happens is through the frameworks and so
I wanted to kind of give a shout out to
all the people that are that are
building tensorflow and PI torch and you
know all the frameworks that people use
to train and deploy these models because
I think that that software stack is
incredibly important and it's changing
rapidly and I think we're gonna see a
lot of advancements there that make deep
learning available for even more
applications nice well Brian thank you
again for joining us we really
appreciate it
great it's been fun
Thanks all right well thank you again
Brian that was great to talk to you
about what's going on at a MIDI and what
kind of research your group is doing and
as we mentioned in the cool things you
know we have the nvidia tesla
v 100's that are the world's most
advanced data center GPU that's going to
be available in the google cloud now I
think it's time for us to dive into
question of the week and so the question
the week roughly is Cheryl mark you both
have been to GDC a lot and you know a
lot about the conference and the
community so what can you tell us as
experts of the space I think I think
Cheryl should go first she's been going
for yeah I think at some point in my
computer science undergrad I was like
the reason I'm in this was to make video
games ever since I was you know five
years old or something and I was like
where do I go to find out so then I
stood I went to my first GDC was like
amazed cuz back then when I was an
undergrad people were like you know
making games like you can't do that for
a living and then I found this this huge
event with like tens of thousands of
people where everybody that's what
everybody did and have been going for 10
years to GDC nice and how long have you
been going for mark 2 years 3 is taking
baby steps compared to Cheryl well
what's your favorite thing about going
to GDC I think this is probably similar
to mark like we both love games we love
playing games we like the idea that
creative space of making games we love
new experiences that come through games
and GDC is where you kind of find the
people that are like us people who are
out there creating and innovating in
this space nice and after you know a few
years it just becomes about connecting
with developers yeah I would I would
echo that 100% what Cheryl said
definitely like it's the people the
diversity of people and the backgrounds
that they have is wonderful it meets so
many people who come from academic
backgrounds with a variety of research
people who come from creative
backgrounds from writing backgrounds
from UX from programming is always a
interesting mix of ideas and people
coming together to produce some often
very interesting things
we're releasing this on a Wednesday as
always it's in the middle of the week in
the middle of the conference but what is
some of the activities that you're like
you must go to this or you must check
this out you know when you go to GDC
especially if you're new to GDC so for
me I think one of the greatest gateways
to GDC is the parties it's great because
like after going once you immediately
notice that it's divided up into
communities as well as you know whole
gathering of game developers and
honestly if you're there I think the IG
DEA Group International Game Developers
Association is always putting out events
- yeah kind of cultivate a great
community within developers in games and
finding a community to plug into is
actually not hard you just have to like
it's just meeting one friend to the next
friend to the next friend and eventually
you'll be like having to be
triple-booked because you're part of so
many different communities I might tell
I'll tell a little story here since
Gerald's here and I think it's always -
the first year I went to GDC I was there
for Google staff the booth did that was
all fine we had a good time was great
next year Cheryl joins Google we
actually met at that booth right I did
meet that was before you joined right
before I joined I was at GDC and I
decided I was like oh I'm gonna go work
for Google like I had already been in
that process I had met with the hiring
manager things were looking good and
then I was right I'm gonna work on Debra
for Google and I got to meet mark for
the first time that I think that was the
first time we met sure yeah that is true
that is true anyway yeah so second year
that I go to GDC Cheryl's on the team
and I'm like we're on a GDC and she's
like cool I'm coming too and doing stuff
as well and she was like but let me let
me show you head of GDC and as at that
point she introduced me to the
Fellowship of GDC potties it's a group
on Facebook every year they get together
and do this crowdsourcing of all the
parties at GDC she introduced me to all
the CAS that are all the volunteers that
run they're not volunteers actually
they're employees to run all the events
you see them wandering around helping
people out and yeah Cheryl was sure was
amazing and really sort of taking me to
that next level of GDC she's like she
took me under her wing and really kind
of showed me that show me the word
she was sure your sage yeah she was my
yeah she was my mentor your mentor
that's fantastic
well that's great and anything else
you'd say like you know make sure to
plug for GGC for this year that you're
like hey don't forget about always
always always always go to old control
GGC that's the the experimental area I
love that place you always see some of
the weirdest stuff I think last year I
saw a game that involve people I'm
having to blow into a box and that was
your interaction and there was two
people on either side it was just weird
there's a lot of weird stuff but it's
also wonderful and you see some really
crazy of like the experimental game
design challenge that Robin Hunicke does
with a group of people and I think the
experimental stuff is definitely very
cool because it's the most for thinking
of the stuff that you'll see you also
see really cool post-mortems of some of
the biggest hits of the last year which
is really interesting to dissect as well
that's fun so in terms of where people
will find you guys next where will
people find you so at GDC itself so
we're sponsoring the women in games
international party which was yesterday
so that doesn't help anybody
on Wednesday itself I will be talking at
3:30 there's a sponsor session we're
doing with firebase and Google cloud so
we're doing a little what's new session
we're talking about a bunch of stuff
there Thursday I will also be talking at
the Google booth doing a little talk on
a Gunners at 12:30 and then doing an ask
the expert session after that for about
an hour as well Cheryl I know you're up
to a bunch of stuff what are you up to
yeah actually GDC you know we're in the
middle of GDC right now there's been
really amazing events that have happened
Google at Google we sponsored blacks in
gaming awards ceremony that happened
yesterday also we're really happy to
have been sponsors of serious games
Awards these are both IG DEA events IG
DEA is an amazing organization that does
a lot in the community of course my talk
was actually yesterday I talked about
machine learning in games just looking
forward I mean Wednesday's kind of the
big day this were like majority the
people show up so Wednesday tonight it's
gonna be it's gonna be a lot of parties
got a lot of parties tomorrow night and
I'll just be kind of hanging around
catching up with people like just
you know kind of a lot of it this is
gonna be lunches with different groups
and different collaborators that I've
had in the past and you both were just
saying before we started recording about
how this year it's it's very heavy
machine learning based is that right I
don't know about heavy but I've
definitely seen that influence there I
mean there's so many sessions that are
JDC for a variety of stuff but I'm
seeing some roundtables I'm seeing a
bunch of talks about a neural networks I
think there's going to be a definite
crossover between AI from a game sense
and an AI from machine learning sense
what do you take on that you you
definitely have much more introspection
into this area that I do yeah well so
one of the things that we're sponsoring
is the AI game developers summit and
they have a reception so we're not
sponsoring the summit itself but yeah
it's interesting because I think there's
been a prehension of deep learning in
games because in games it's really easy
to create cognitive dissonance in an
experience it's interesting that like
now we're in a day where deep learning
effectiveness has gone up by so much
that we're trying to figure out how to
leverage this technology to create
better deeper more immersive games so I
will ask one last question for both of
you
oh favorite game oh that's easy so for
me still it's III still put it out to
the mass effect series I'm just a huge
fan if that whole world loved the
writing let the direction but just huge
fan yeah for me
Final Fantasy mine my twitter handle is
FF paladin and Final Fantasy has just
it's the game that made me want to make
games so it's got to be a favorite but I
have to save and play a lot of
hearthstone that dungeon crawl is so
good I don't know if you've played it
mark but it's really good no no while
actually I'm in the middle of big
Bioware binge talking am a mess effect
I've been playing Dragon Age Origins so
I went back to the beginning I've gone
back to the beginning and I'm just gonna
play all the way through all of it
that's just I'm just having so much fun
yeah I've been wanting to play that
series I've heard a lot I haven't
actually played that many Western RPGs
but it's good hearthstone you have to
try it out like like just log in and do
the dungeon crawl it's like excellent
game design and really fun they did a
really good job with that nice cool I
will check it out well cool
alright well anything else you both
wanted to talk about in regards to GDC
the
we didn't her to cover my last advice is
just to just bring a lot of business
cards because your aunt you end up
meeting so many people and you'll leave
with a huge stack of contacts definitely
well great thanks again Cheryl I'm so
glad you were able to join us and I'll
do one little less plug that has nothing
to do with GDC and instead mention GTC
which is in videos technology it's their
GPU technology conference that's coming
up and that's going to be next week so
just give a little shout out to that and
then Cheryl you had one other thing the
tensorflow dev summit ah it's next week
tensorflow dev summit is coming up and
that's gonna have a live stream talks
and the talks will definitely be there
afterwards I'm actually speaking about
machine learning research and creativity
so definitely check that out as well
thanks for covering it anything else
Marc that we wanted to mention before we
close out this week I plan on sleeping a
lot after GDC that's so no one can find
you yeah don't look for you taking some
time off you're done for the rest of the
year listen well Melanie Cheryl thank
you so much for joining us for yet
another episode of the podcast thanks so
much for having me thank you
take care wonderful and thank you all
for listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]